well on clubhouse and on youtube
watching this very special episode of
the into the impossible podcast
with uh dr dan hooper who is a physicist
and a professor at university of
california and a university of
california wish
i wish you see that freudian slipped in
uh
what's that you're trying to recruit me
i would i would love it you know
that would be uh it's not so uh common
to find intellects like yours i would
certainly love that
and i know my colleagues would feel the
same let's talk about that afterwards
maybe i can convince
them my ultimate boss um so uh
dan and i have been friends for a long
time he's a podcast host
he is also the author of a wonderful
book which i reviewed and i think i
actually
put my encomium my blurb on the back uh
for this wonderful book called at the
edge of time
exploring the mysteries of our
universe's first seconds
and that book i compare to stephen
weinberg's a brief history a brief
history of time
again i'm making all these freudian
slips with you dan it shows you how much
i respect you
um i compared it to stephen weinberg's
first three minutes and it kind of
updated it
for the modern age and i found that to
be such a delightful read
i recommend everybody get that now dan
is a theoretical
physicist he is not a member of the g
minus two team
as far as i know uh that's correct
there's almost nobody better
on this theoretical particle physics
side to come
and talk about the importance of this
measurement
that was announced this morning and uh
you know
i just found out about it you know about
a month ago when they started you know
kind of tweeting about it hinting about
it releasing stuff
um i've had my experiences with you know
press conferences and media releases
uh first of all what do you make of the
of the way that this was announced and
kind of hinted at and teased for the
last couple months from
the otherwise pretty staid and reserved
fermilab institution where you call
partially is one of your homes yeah i
mean so this is the sort of experiment
that's been
going on for years and years and years
and for those of us who were
on the ground following it we've been
begging for information this whole time
we keep asking for updates we like when
are we going to learn when are we going
to learn
when are we going to find out and i mean
given how much pressure they were under
to tell us things
i think they were remarkably you know
conservative
and and careful in in the roll out of
all this
um it's pretty hard i mean it's 200
scientists
and um i know i couldn't find out what
the answer was
until this morning so clearly they're
they're being pretty cautious
about uh keeping their lips tight and uh
and things on the up and up
and so um this was at fermilab where you
uh spend part of your time
tell us what is fermilab how does it
compare to the lhc just last week on
this podcast
we had on um uh or two weeks ago now it
was uh dr james beacham
of cern talking about the large hadron
collider beauty experiment which also
has some evidence for new physics
strange new forces particles forces and
fields
what is fermilab um what role does it
play now i thought you know
cern was where it's at after the higgs
discovery uh in 2012.
well i mean i certainly don't want to
minimize the importance of the lhc the
large hadron collider
is the world's premier what we call an
energy frontier experiment these are
these are experiments that try to put as
much energy at one place at one time and
study laws of physics that way
but there are other kinds of ways that
we do particle physics experiments as
well
in particular we do precision
measurements at lower energy
things that the lhc can't do and the g
minus two experiment at fermilab is an
example of that
i'm in the past
indigue's particle accelerator prior to
the large pattern collider and the
tevatron was the flagship experiment at
fermilab for a long time
and uh i for one you know am optimistic
that
someday in the future fermilab will
build another big particle accelerator
in that sort of vein
right now we're doing things like a lot
of precision neutrino experiments which
are very exciting
we're doing precision muon experiments
like the g minus two experiment among
others
um in a variety of other things like
this so there's a lot of particle
physics that can be done that's
complementary to what cern and the large
hadron collider can do
and a lot of that's going on at fermilab
and what role did brookhaven
in this as well um my understanding is
brookhaven had an earlier result
and um and it was a little less
significant and now the combination of
two
ultra precise measurements of this
phenomena which you promise you will
explain in just a bit
now lead to an an enhanced understanding
of certain anomalies
and it's always like um who was it
leonard uh cohen
said you know the cracks or lights get
light gets in
so i want to ask uh first of all what is
the brookhaven experiment what did that
do and what
lacunae or gaps that it have in our
understand leave in our understanding of
this
uh aspect of experimental particle
physics yeah so a lot of experiments are
done
at the various national labs around uh
the department of energy national labs
around around the country brookhaven's
is is one of them
and uh back in the early 2000s they
measured
the the same quantity that the [ __ ]
lab experiment measured it's called the
muon's magnetic moment or sometimes
called g minus two
and this was uh the experiment uh called
the e
821 experiment it's a not a very
romantic name but it gets the job done
um and they measured this quantity and
found that it was different from what
the theory predicted
it made a lot of us very excited and
interested but
we always wondered well maybe they
measured it wrong maybe it was statistic
a statistical fluke
um these sorts of questions lingered and
i think as of today with fermilab's
announcement
well i'm still not sure we're completely
certain how to think about it but it
wasn't a statistical fluke
and it wasn't just a mismeasurement i
think we can rule those two things out
to a high degree of confidence uh
either this is telling us something new
about the laws of physics
or the problem is on the theory side the
theorists trying to calculate what they
think this number
should be and now talking about
fermilab itself of course is named after
enrico fermi
uh who had not a small connection to
many of our understandings of the
uh both the evolution of the universe
since its origin
and uh and certainly the particle
dynamics the manhattan project
uh so fermi national laboratory is
located uh what about 80
70 miles outside of chicago where you
uh teach at the university of chicago
yeah so
um if you drive due west from chicago
and i actually live right on the chicago
city limit essentially um you can get
the fermi lab in half an hour or so
so that gives you an idea but when it
was built you know 50 years ago
it was in corn fields now it's in a you
know network of suburbs
and uh of course enrico fermi also has
no small impact
on things even as diverse ranging from
atomic
atomic fission to the search for
aliens and perhaps the lack of
observations of aliens
i wonder if you could briefly comment on
that the so-called fermi paradox to set
the stage
for mysterious things that are
associated with the name fermi and then
we'll get into this specific particle
called the muon and then
why it's behaving anomalously yeah so
one of my favorite things about
about enrico fermi but really many of my
favorite scientists
is just how intellectually curious they
were or
are and how many different subjects they
found themselves
investigating over the courses of their
career and this isn't just fermi but
many of the
many of these great scientists fall in
that category
so i mean he worked out the basic
principles behind cosmic ray
acceleration that's something i work on
he worked out a lot of the stuff related
to our views of
nuclear physics and particle physics as
they were kind of first
coming together and as you mentioned he
is is named for the [ __ ] paradox
basically
asking the question of you know if if
life seems
readily uh you know ready you know very
easy
to uh uh evolve from spontaneous
conditions then and there's so many
planets and so many stars around the
milky way
you know why haven't we seen any
evidence of intelligent life trying to
communicate with us or traveling around
or something like this so
that's sometimes called the fermi
paradox i don't think it's actually all
that paradoxical
but it's a good question to ask and it
leads you to some important conclusions
about the nature of life in the milky
way and elsewhere
yeah one thing i've always associated
with fermi and his mischievous
um really amazing personality and sense
of humor etc
were his famous fermi paradoxes and
fermi paradoxes are type of
guesstimation or physics
by order of magnitude solution and
uh it's kind of interesting to me that
the some of the most precision science
is done
at this place named after a person who
came up with
a very qualitative way of approaching
problems i mean what what are do you
have one of your favorite uh fermi
paradox
fermi uh questions so to speak
oh i've heard so many of them um but
yeah i mean he had a way
of saying well you don't have to know
any of the details
of the question at hand all you have to
do is you can you ask questions like you
know how many
piano tuners do you think there are in
new york city and he could get a pretty
good answer
without knowing anything about piano
tuners and he would approach
science in the same sort of way and you
would be amazed at how much power there
is
in this sort of order magnitude thinking
that he would apply
yeah absolutely and i and i see again
you are a master
communicator the way that fermi was and
really taking on this this kind of uh
goal that you do to not only keep
science you know
thriving via the very highly qualitative
quantitative
predictions that you make on subjects as
diverse as the origin of the universe
the evolution of the universe the
composition of the universe
and thereof new theories new concepts
but also popularizing it
for for ordinary lay people and i want
to commend you for that you have a
wonderful podcast
and i only say this you know it's weird
dan if you ever think about it
i think kurt vonnegut said that no
writer should ever give a blurb to
another writer
because explicitly she is or he is
saying
don't read my book read this other guys
or girls book instead
and yet i still gave my encomium to you
because it was such a fabulous book and
i hope that you'll write many more you
wrote
cosmos and other books but also the
thing that really
and i have a video on my channel where
now i'm coming uh i haven't released it
yet
on into the impossible where i'm
reviewing other science podcasts
um you came on the podcast but now uh on
the into the impossible podcast
soon i'll review and i'm only reviewing
yours uh sean carroll's
uh brandon drachlers and um and jorge
cham
and um and then uh daniel whitman's
um uh podcast as well uh but why this
universe
say one thing about why you started that
podcast and what it means to you and
what your mission is with that wonderful
podcast
i mean i've always enjoyed communicating
physics and science
to a non-technical audience to people
who are intellectually curious but maybe
haven't had the opportunity to spend all
the years
you know learning the math and uh
coursework that it takes to
to you read the journal articles that's
why i wrote the books that i wrote
um and i always kind of wanted to do it
in a podcast format i thought that would
be fun i
i like audio a lot as a format i'm less
a video guy um
but i i didn't have the you know kind of
technical chops to know how to
you know produce or otherwise you know
do the engineering of a podcast
and then there was this this undergrad
uh shulma wegsman who
uh i was doing some research projects
with at the university of chicago
and in kind of a mentor role i asked her
one day well what courses are you taking
next quarter
and she's listed off several math and
physics courses and then said and also
this small
course on introduction to podcasting
like oh that's interesting
so we got to talking about it and uh you
know a few months later we started our
wireless universe podcast uh we're still
doing an
episode every two weeks and um in fact
just today we recorded a little segment
on g minus two so watch for that in your
feed
yeah i can't wait it'll be one of the
ones i review and i'm putting a link to
it
in the uh visuals as well as an uh
picture of the podcast you can follow it
in shalma and dan
uh dan is at dan hooper astro on
the twitter feed and i'm reminding you
we're live on the into the impossible
podcast
network which is not much of a network
but i do have
some amazing guests this week i had on
john mather winner of the 2006
co-recipient of the 2006 nobel prize for
his work on the kobe satellite and he
and i talked a lot about uh
mentorship and how good scientists need
good problems to solve and i have a book
coming up called think like a nobel
prize winner
which i feel the secrets of the nine
nobel laureates who've been on my
podcast on itunes uh every spotify get
it but also on youtube
and one of the things he said to me is
give your students impossible problems
and that's one of the lessons he learned
from david wilkinson
now the reason i bring up david
wilkinson is because he was my he is my
grand advisor he was my phd advisor
peter timbe's
phd advisor at princeton and i got to
know him a little bit uh
the wmaps satellite is named after him
um
david wilkinson's phd thesis was g minus
two
so there's a nice little thread going
through this uh where
today's episode into the impossible
normal interview with john mather
mentions david wilkinson who said
you know you basically have to give your
students the feeling that they're
invincible
and the way you do that is give them
impossible problems i wonder if you can
say one thing about that before we move
to g minus two
what the heck is it people are screaming
in the chat get to the anomaly man
uh no no that's purely my speculation
but my audience is the best and
brightest
maybe alongside of yours but i think i
expect we have quite a good deal of
overlap between our podcast audiences
anyway what do you think about
mentorship do scientists have an
obligation to be
mentors or can we just kind of stay in
the theory or the experimental cave
and just grind out awesome science so
mentorship is if not the most important
thing we do it's it's one of the most
important things we do
and if you went around and asked a bunch
of professional physicists what they
thought of that 10 years ago
i think you'd get a very different
answer than you get today
ten years ago i heard a lot of
professors and other
senior scientists say things like all
you have to do
is you know give a good student
opportunities to
you know be around smart people and the
good ones will find good projects and
you can basically leave it
to them to sort out and
i would say that attitude has all but
gone extinct
in the circles i'm around anyway i think
there's a much greater appreciation that
that leaves that sort of approach leaves
out a lot of students and not just
students but postdocs and other like
junior
scientists who are still uh you know
finding their way through the
through the academic landscape and uh
i think this is is turning into a a much
better
place for people to study physics and
astronomy
leading to a much greater variety of
people who are thriving and succeeding
in the field
uh it takes advantage of different kinds
of personality types and different kinds
of thinking
that maybe were being excluded from our
community before so i
i think uh mentorship and other
way other non-classroom ways of training
is
is uh is not only important but it's
finally getting the
recognition it's a long head due yeah i
i'm kind of
picked lately that scientists have a
moral obligation to communicate
our work and as you'll about to hear
those of you
uh watching on youtube listening on
clubhouse or on a podcast after it comes
out
you know there's really no one better to
explain these extremely um
complicated uh you know puzzles within
science
than dan or the other guests i get to
have on the podcast and i always say dan
you know as an experimentalist a lot of
things i have to do
i have to talk to contractors who drive
concrete up to seventeen thousand feet
in chile to talk to you know someone
who's supplying a ball bearing
that has an out of roundness spec of one
part per million
and that's not it's actually two parts
per milli you know so i have to talk to
these people and sometimes
but i get to talk to people i want to
talk to on the podcast
and in doing i like to say that you know
we as scientists we get paid by the
public
and now imagine and this is true at
formula fermilab is a national
government national laboratory
arguably the best in the world are you
know tied for the best in the world of
any kind but nevertheless
you and i as a public employee of the
state of california are paid by the
taxpayers
and i believe we have a moral obligation
to fulfill to those taxpayers
to explain what we do in terms that they
can understand so again i really want to
commend you and shalma
for the work that you as scientists do
because you know imagine you went to a
doctor i always say and they said well
you can't understand what i'm you know
you didn't go to medical school you're
not going to understand this diagnosis
but you've got to have this thing in
your body cut off
you'd say go you know go jump off a lake
and you'd get a second opinion but how
can we get a second opinion
if scientists aren't willing to really
explicate what we do
so now my audience is going nuts they're
i've been teasing them for so long
what the heck is a muon
good so a muon is a particle
uh indivisible piece of energy
that we've known about since you know
nearly 100 years ago and it's a lot like
an electron you can think of it as a
cousin
of the electron but it's heavier it's
about 200 times
more massive than an electron and
whereas an electron if you just
put it out there in the universe it will
stick around probably forever as far as
we know they're completely stable
the muon decays awfully quickly if you
wait a million seconds or so
there's a you know roughly even odds
chance that that muon will disappear
being replaced by an electron and some
neutrinos it will decay
so you can think of the muon as a
unstable heavy version of the electron
and when they decay what do they decay
into i thought energy was uh
indestructible so if it's a particle of
energy what could it possibly decay into
so the energy doesn't go anywhere you
want have exactly the same energy before
and after the decay
but the energy was originally stored up
in the masses
that muon's gone when it's decayed there
are new particles namely an electron and
three different neutrinos i'm sorry
that's wrong two different neutrinos
and those those three particles and
carry away the energy that the muon
originally had stored in its mass
and when it uh that that decay product
uh
really the muon hasn't been known for
all that long
and in fact it caused some consternation
when it was discovered
and yet it's one of the most ubiquitous
articles in nature so
was it not itself unexpected and if so
why would you expect something
unexpected
to have properties that you can
understand
well so the short answer is we just
didn't know very much about particle
physics when the muon was discovered so
it was surprising
from the you know perspective of what
was known at the time
at the time really all we knew about
were electrons protons and neutrons and
light
and we didn't have any reason to expect
there to be really anything
else um we now know that the universe is
full of a variety of forms of energy
there are you know the standard model of
particle physics our best theory
of the quantum world contains six
particles called
quarks six particles called leptons and
then four other particles we call bosons
the muon is one of those six kinds of
leptons
and these particles all kind of fit
together in a neat
uh orderly fashion if you took any one
of these particles away the standard
model wouldn't work anymore it wouldn't
be self-consistent
it has to come as kind of a complete
package and
uh the to answer your question of why do
we think we should be able to understand
what the properties of the muon should
be
i would say the short answer is because
every time we test a standard model
we find that it gives the right answer
it doesn't matter how many
you know digits of precision we
calculate and measure
we just keep getting the same answer
everything the standard model is
predicted to date
has borne out an experiment until
perhaps today
now um it was first discovered it was
discovered more or less serendipitously
as i understand it
and the famous uh nobel laureate uh
rabbi
robbie robbie said uh famously who
ordered that
as if uh this was surprising and yet it
was our first clue into the next
generations of leptons as you mentioned
that were heretofore unexpected and so
in summary without the muon we would
have many more puzzles than we do with
the muon
in the sense it solves more puzzles than
that brings up
which is both good and bad it's good
because it answers it gives us some
closure but it's bad in that
you know maybe there's pointing to a
signal that that we've come to the end
of a road and
it's always more fun to know that more
to explore um
what are the properties of muons as i
understand it and from what you just
said
they're kind of like commodities you
know you've seen one muon
they're kind of like fungible tokens we
talk about bitcoin
on this channel on occasion and i know
uh you know fermilab must have a whole
you know super computer center developed
just to mining bitcoin no it doesn't do
that
don't i don't think the us government is
spending its money doing that uh
but uh but nevertheless um the the muon
is fungible in the sense that every muon
is like every other mu is it not
i mean that's true about every kind of
particle in the universe uh
whether i'm talking about muons or
photons or electrons
there is no difference whatsoever
between two instances of that kind of
particle
um if i took the universe and i and i
stopped it
and i replaced two muons with each other
literally nothing would change and i
don't mean just that it would be hard to
measure or something i mean
literally nothing would change the
universe would be exactly the same
afterwards as it was before
so if i have a muon and i just created
it in a particle
collision and i have another muon and it
was born in the big bang and it's been
flying along ever since
of course that's very unlikely because
it's so short-lived but just go with the
thought experiment you still nothing you
could
ever do could ever discriminate or
distinguish
those two muons because those two muons
are exactly alike
there's no difference whatsoever and so
it has charge
um it has mass it has that's right
it has uh presumably has spin and now my
question is what is a magnetic moment
what does that mean that something has a
magnetic moment and then what does it
mean to have an anomalous magnetic
moment
so good so if you take a particle like a
muon or electron or whatever
and you put it in a magnetic field it
will kind of
spin around on an axis it will precess
around its axis so you can think of it
as
let's say i take a american football and
i throw it
and have a nice spiral to it but now
imagine that in addition to that spiral
it's kind of processing around its axis
okay
um that's what a muon will do in the
present
magnetic field from like a top
in the presence of the magnetic field we
talk about it in terms of this number
the magnetic magnetic moment and that
number tells us how fast this particular
kind of particle
will process or spin like a top in the
presence of that magnetic field
and in a magnetic field the electron
also behaves
uh anomalously to some extent and that's
what my
my phd advisor's advisor david wilkinson
was studying g minus two for an election
so what is
g and you know i tweeted out yesterday
you know g minus two i thought that was
you know the gravitational constant nine
point eight meters per second so
g minus two is going to be 7.8 meters
per second
obviously i don't know what i'm talking
about as usual but
g what is g what does it parameterize
why is it interesting
to physicists why is it causing such a
huge stir today
good so uh in the
in in in the context of the magnetic
moment of muon
g is this number which
if the how do i put it so
if the simplest version
of quantum mechanics could be used to
reliably predict the magnetic moment of
the muon
g would be exactly two so when we
measure
g minus two what you're getting at
is the small departures from that simple
version of quantum mechanics
in particular you're getting all the
quantum effects of virtual particles
popping
into existence and interacting with the
photon in the magnetic field
and it's slight differences from what
you would get from the direct
interaction
so we're looking at tiny little quantum
effects that that
impact this quantity just a little bit
and impact the way which just spins like
a top
um changing in subtle ways that we can
measure
uh differences uh about how a
muon behaves in the presence of that
magnetic field
and so uh let me just take a step back
to introduce there's over 260 people
watching on youtube there's many more on
clubhouse we're talking to
professor dr uh dan hooper who is the
proprietor of
buy this universe podcast and also
uh author of a great deal of books
including one that
he uh he allowed me i should say to be
a part of in a small way by giving my
best blurb to
which was uh the best that i could do at
and least and that was to say what a
wonderful book and how it reminded me
so much of uh of stephen weinberg's
apocal uh first three minutes
and that book is at the edge of time are
exploring the mysteries of our
universe's first seconds
now many people get excited about new
quantum mechanical forces and fields
and even go into the esoterica of things
that we have not been able to measure we
have not been able to
come up with the so-called theory of
everything and this week i'll be talking
tomorrow in fact with neil degrasse
tyson um and then i'm talking with
um with michio kaku who has a new book
out
again competing with us these guys they
don't stop writing books
uh and that book is called the god
equation in which he makes the case that
string theory has somehow
um you know kind of solved or will solve
these problems i want to get to that
in the philosophy of why these things
are so
important but first i want to get your
take on
on why did these particular measurements
why do they attract so much attention
that fermilab a very staid
a very placid organization would take
such great pains to really publicize the
heck out of it as if it's a
new ios offering from our our friends at
apple
well i mean you said yourself before
that it's important
an important part of our job as as a
scientific citizens
to communicate uh what we know about the
universe to
the people who support us financially
and otherwise um i would say that
fermilab is simply doing its job
uh it's it's responsibility of the
public to
you know promote this and talk about it
when they have a really exciting result
like this and they do have a very
exciting result here it's worth sharing
it's worth promoting it's a in my
opinion doing uh the public
service by making sure as many of them
hear about this as possible
and um and of course they kept it secret
and it was embargoed i understand
there's a paper
today um and that paper was embargoed
obviously for quite some time
uh the actual announcement said uh
approximately one in i think four
thousand it was at the four sigma
approximate level now i just one in
forty thousand
forty thousand forty thousand right
that's right um and that corresponds to
four sigma my late great particle
physics colleague who is a student of
leon letterman
a famous nobel laureate his name is hans
parr he was here at uc san diego he said
at three sigma
they invite you to give a seminar um and
they don't
pay you back reimbursement expenses at
five sigma
they invite you to stockholm now where
is this thing in that
obviously in four sigma it's it's kind
of obviously
halfway between three and five but but
that there's much more to that
to coming to a complete conclusion so
can you speculate a little bit or
explain a little bit
what does this mean the sigma that we
talk about
good so so um we have this tradition
specifically in particle physics not
throughout science but specifically in
particle physics
that we don't use the word discovery
until it
meets this exceedingly high standard of
statistical significance known as five
sigma
the odds that you will get five sigma by
pure chance
as a fake signal of something is almost
zero so
if you have a five sigma detection of
something you can
be rest assured that either you've
really measured it and it's real
or you just screwed up but it's not
going to be a statistical fluke it could
be a mistake but it won't be a
statistical fluke
um if you instead we're looking for
things at the two sigma level
something like one out of twenty times
that will come up just by chance
um at the three sigma level a few times
in a thousand you'll get something by
chance
at the 4.2 sigma level which this one is
only
one in 40 000 times when you get
something this wrong by
chance so before fermilab went on this
on this uh mission to measure this we
already had an independent measurement
from the people at brookhaven
and fermilab's new result agrees with
that
so i think we can be very confident now
that what we're not looking at here is a
statistical fluke
and what we're not looking at here is
just some sort of simple mismeasurement
or some sort of mistake
made by the experimentalists either
we're looking at new physics something
beyond the standard model new particles
or forces that we don't currently know
about
interacting in a way that changes the
magnetic moment of the muon is the way
that we're
observing it or the theorists have not
gotten their
their uh their task uh have not done
their task very well
and the very very difficult theoretical
calculations that go into this
are just a little bit off and that could
explain the anomaly as well
my bet at this point is that this is
really new physics
i think the theory calculations look
pretty good that being said if something
goes wrong
it's the theory calculation at this
point okay so that brings up
a controversial aspect of this discovery
in that we're always comparing
a model or an expectation uh to
uh observation or deducting deductively
uh
you know drawing conclusions as to what
will be the implications of our theory
if it's true
in one hand i call that the deductive
scientific method there's also the
inductive
where you might discover something new
and then try to fit a theory to that
discovery this is something that people
have been looking for and so
is there not a possibility of bias on
the experimentalist
side of things uh i know you mentioned
the theory might be you know obviously
you know is there not a bias to you know
potentially overcome and if so
how do you guard against this bias as
feynman said
uh not to fool yourself as your first
principle of operation
yeah so in in this case especially these
experimentalists went they bent over
backwards to make sure that their own
biases could not pollute or
contaminate their their final result
they had the the data blinded no one
could see it
and they they uh they kind of coded the
result in a way
that they couldn't get the final answer
to until these numbers that have been
sealed
often and held by uh by people outside
the collaboration
had to decode so they did their whole
experiment they measured everything they
had their data they
and then they decoded it and found out
what the answer was and by then it was
locked in
um this this is uh exactly what you want
for a
scientific collaboration to do it it is
uh the very
highest standard of scientific
reliability
um i don't think there's any plausible
way that they've simply mismeasured this
and so their paper that was in nature
today
has a very very attractive title uh one
that would
easily make it a bestseller if it were
your next book's title
then leading hadronic contribution to
the muon magnet
moment from lattice qcd now my audience
is second to none
uh and they have great depth and
facility
in their intellectual uh parapotetism
and other buzzwords but um
what is lattice qcd and what is it
useful for in the context uh first of
all what is qcd
what is lattice qcd let's go there first
because you traffic can i even
i think we need to even back up further
brian so
let me kind of sketch what the theory
calculation behind this like looks for
that if
the only thing at play where the muon
and the photon it was interacting with
this g factor would be exactly two but
when you include
virtual particles that are popping into
existence and interacting
then it gets slightly different from two
and when you do that
with processes that involve just like
one little loop of particles
you you get a certain number and then if
you include things with
two loops of particles you get a
slightly more precise number
and if you do three loops of particles
you get a slightly
more accurate number and you have to
include all the different kinds of
particles
that can come into existence and do
these things it's very very complicated
it's very very technical and eventually
you reach a point where some of this
stuff
can't be done by the simple what we call
perturbative means we need to use
other mathematical techniques to do this
some of these
are rely on experimental results these
are usually called r ratio processor
techniques methods and and they get one
particular
uh prediction for this sort of stuff but
another way of doing it is is as you
said uh
using these techniques called lattice
qcd so qcd
is quantum chromodynamics it's our
theory of the strong force it is a very
very well tested and accurate theory
um but it's also a notoriously difficult
theory to use in certain circumstances
and to get around those problems people
use very powerful computers
to simulate the interactions of these
these uh quarks and gluons that carry
the strong force
and we say we do it on the lattice so we
we have a computer calculation
using very powerful computers that is
the attempt that's what lattice qcd
scientists are trying to do
and those groups using those techniques
can make very precise calculations of
what the magnetic moment of the muon
should be
and there are other techniques as well
but the paper that
came out in nature today is making one
of the estimates or one of the
calculations using lattice qcd for how
big the magnetic moment
of the muon should be if the standard
model is the correct theory of nature
now how did people like um schwinger and
other people make calculations if they
didn't have
supercomputers computers were barely in
their infancy they didn't have qcd
you know i had an interview with shelly
glashau who
was held by his advisor julian schwinger
to look at this phenomenon
you know this is 60 years ago he was on
the into the impossible podcast and will
be in my upcoming book
think like a nobel prize winner uh but
nevertheless uh this was not possible to
really um unravel until computers like
this were available so is it just a case
of synergy where the experiment
and the um and the theory it sort of
lockstep with with
uh moore's equation moore's law and
that's really what's dominating progress
both experimentally and theoretically
so you mentioned julian schwinger i mean
he he was the first one to calculate the
one
loop version of this calculation for the
muens magnetic moment
i think that was back in the late 40s
and uh
that's great that i mean that's
incredibly incredible accomplishment my
understanding is that equation is on its
tombstone of all things
um yes but but to but to compete with
the precision at which we can measure
this now
that's not good enough you need to go to
two and three loops and et cetera
and the incredibly precise calculations
and to do that you need to know about
things like qcd you need to know
about things like the detailed
interactions of all the particles that
go around in these complicated loops
and you can't do that without kind of
the modern technologies like lattice qcd
provide us with
and i don't think it's exactly a
coincidence that these calculations are
coming
to bear now they are coming to bear in
large part because we knew this
experiment
was going to be done and we knew it was
going to be important to have these
theory calculations
so we invested in it a huge army of
theoretical physicists who specialize in
these sorts of techniques
have been spending years if not decades
trying to do this
if it weren't for this particular
experiment and this particular
measurement
i don't think we would have these
calculations at this level of precision
yeah and surely the it's the precision
where the detail
devils uh lie and also as you mentioned
in an experiment it's
important to avoid the bias the
selection effect bias etc
um i want to turn to a philosophical
question before we get uh
take questions from clubhouse uh and
before i take some questions from the
youtube audience
of now close to 400 people watching uh
don't be nervous
uh but uh but you're used to this as a
big shot podcaster again
we're talking to dan hooper one of my
favorite uh competitors
in the podcasting landscape because he
is uh so genuine so interested
in public uh outreach and excitement of
the work that he does and his colleagues
and our colleagues really
that he started this channel with
charlemagne wegsman who is another
up-and-coming brilliant superstar to be
and already
and uh he's also the book uh author of
uh
at the edge of time right um and so what
i want to
uh kind of open up now before we get
really theoretical and start talking
about you know the s word string word
i do want to get into that with people
in clubhouse especially
but i do want to ask the question about
uh whether or not we have
uh really a reason to trust in these
virtual photons
i'm putting up on screen an article by
natty walkover at
quantum magazine which is an independent
journal sponsored by the simon's
foundation
um and that uh that article she talks
about the entourage
these virtual particles are like an
entourage uh
what what what is a virtual photon all
right so
in as we understand quantum field theory
or quantum physics
um particles can spontaneously come into
existence they
they uh they're not permanent things
they're fleeting things
so if i have for example uh electron
passing through space
that electron can emit a new
photon which then quickly gets
reabsorbed and now i've got what i call
a one
loop correction to the behavior of that
electron
um i can also do things like
uh you know particle mean traveling
along and it for a very brief period of
time you could have a particle come into
existence
that maybe is very heavy and it contains
in principle a lot of energy more energy
than you started with
and that particle can exist for a very
brief period of time
it seems to violate energy conservation
and it's in a certain sense it does
but as long as the energy is only
created for a very short period of time
that's completely
consistent with the laws of quantum
physics as we understand them
and we call a particle like that a
virtual particle as opposed to an on
shell or real particle it's a
it's a particle that only exists briefly
and its effects
are are felt uh indirectly through the
subtle influences on other matter we
observe
and uh do we have evidence experimental
evidence of virtual particles are they
just a
convent a convenient theoretical
bookkeeping tool
uh invented to you know cause some kind
of ponzi scheme to be avoided
no i mean there's there's no doubt that
virtual particles exist
um when we calculate when we use the
standard model including all the virtual
corrections to calculate any number of
things and compare them
with observational or experimental
results
we just get the right answer every
single time with the exception of today
perhaps
um in fact this is why today is so
exciting
this is the first time where we're
seeing this isn't working okay we're
we're finding a departure
and that probably is telling us or
either it's telling us that we
calculated it wrong which i think we
have to
at least acknowledge as a possibility
but if that turns out not to be the case
what it's telling us is that there are
other virtual particles in those loops
that we
don't currently include in our theory so
some bigger
theory that will supersede the standard
model will come in and explain why this
number
was just a little bit different this is
how many
uh you know pertinence to looking for
evidence
or super symmetry or other extensions
you know beyond the standard model
so to speak physics so sure um
super symmetry is one of the contenders
for what could explain
what fermilab announced today if there
are particles and predicted by
supersymmetry
they go by names of the smuon or the
muons neutrino and along with particles
we call gay genos these are all things
that are
predicted in any supersymmetric theory
if those particles exist and they're a
few hundred gb in mass so a few hundred
times heavier than a protons say
they could account for this uh anomaly
this
this this result that we're reporting
but it's not the only idea there are
other ideas too
um one that i've worked on is you could
have a
new light force carriers so these would
be particles kind of like a photon with
a little bit of mass
that couple preferentially to muons
that's the sort of or
i should i should avoid that technical
language they interact
preferentially with muons that's what i
mean by couple
these are the sorts of things that could
do it as well and there are other ideas
so
at this moment we don't know we can't
narrow we can only begin to narrow down
the list of possibilities
um but in the years to come we would
hope to
rule out as many of these as possible
focusing on the ones that are most
likely maybe
directly observe the particles that are
responsible
at a machine like large hadron collider
in the case of supersymmetry
or in the case of lighter particles
maybe some sort of other
lower energy high precision experiment
remind everybody we're talking with
professor dan hooper of university
chicago
and fermilab uh theoretical physicist
cosmologist
has made foundational contributions to
our understanding of the standard model
but also beyond the standard model
particular with dark matter
um now this particular um
discovery is again related to this
fungible property of
you know all all particles are the same
some are more the same than others i
suppose
are there other ways to get at this from
a i know you're not an experimentalist
and this is more my purview but i'm not
a particle experimentalist and it's very
specialized what these folks are doing
and i have
great respect for them as i indicated to
james beacham when he was on two weeks
ago to talk about the
lhc beauty experiment which find that on
my youtube channel dr brian keating
these discoveries are enhanced i would
say when experimental teams find the
same
result from two completely different
directions are there other properties of
the muon say it's electrical properties
is there an anomalous electrical moment
that could be observed
are there other ways with conventional
standard model physics
techniques that could reveal beyond the
standard model
theoretical uh revelations
yeah i mean there are there any particle
including the muon has a long list of
properties
um and in some cases those properties
those detailed properties are predicted
by the theory
in this case the standard model and
those provide really
you know rich grounds to test the
standard model especially when we can
measure those properties at
very very high precision um and
in the g minus two experiment at
fermilab is really only the beginning of
our muon program there are other
muon related uh measurements that are
are
planned for the years and decades ahead
um
in terms of testing inter possible
explanations for the the g minus two
anomaly though
we might do that with the particles that
don't involve muons at all
so for example the large hadron collider
by colliding protons together we might
be able to produce and observe those
supersymmetric particles that might be
going on in the loops
that that's that kind of tweak the
magnetic moment of the muon in the way
that fermilab is observing
we might also be able to use really low
energy
relatively low energy neutrino collision
experiments
to look for these uh trident events
which would would test another
class of explanations uh for the
g minus two anomaly so you can get at
the same
physics it turns out from a lot of
different directions and i agree with
you
if you saw evidence for the same
underlying physics from several
different directions several different
kinds of experiments and probing
different kinds of phenomena
you'd be more confident that you
understand what you're what you're
really looking at and that makes sense
in the context of some bigger theory
okay great thanks for that um so we're
gonna take some questions from
uh first from youtube and then from
clubhouse uh we have about a hundred
plus people listening
and we'll open up the room there in just
a bit but the first question on youtube
that i saw that caught my attention was
why does qcd have anything to say about
a muon
in other words why why does this you
know theory of the
strong force which you might explain
very briefly what does that have to do
with the theory of of leptons
so um when i'm calculating the magnetic
moment of the muon
i have to if i want to do it at the kind
of level of precision we're talking
about here you need to include all the
different kinds of particles that can go
around in these loops
that connect a muon to the photons that
make up the magnetic field
so this at the one loop level the one
the kind of calculation that was done
back in the 1940s and 50s i mean these
involved uh the weak force carriers the
w
and z bosons and muons and neutrinos
things like this
at the two loop you need to worry about
other kinds of particles that three loop
you need to worry about other kinds of
particles and this includes things like
quarks and gluons or equivalently we can
think about them as things like pions
which are glued
or bound states of quarks and gluons so
all these things come into
play if you if you ignored the quarks
and gluons in your calculation you
wouldn't get anything close to the right
answer
so you need to include all of the forms
of matter and energy that exists in the
standard model to get this calculation
correct at the level of precision that
you need to to test the standard model
in this sort of experiment
what would be most likely to improve the
uh understanding it would be advances
and it seems like we'll saturate
eventually on how much fermilab can do
although you mentioned some other
experiments
in natalie's article wonderful article i
encourage everyone to follow her natty
over
twitter writing for quantum magazine she
says that the last
hope experiment called it a last hope
experiment
and and that kind of hints at you know
kind of the these you know hail mary
type events and stuff that you don't
normally like to hear about
uh but what does that mean necessarily
that the hail mary
um and then where is improvement likely
to occur
more rapidly in the theoretical
direction or in the experimental front
well i mean both the answer is is going
to be a concerted effort
not just in terms of theory but then
lots of different kinds of theory
and not just experiment but lots of
different experiments all contributing
to this story
on the theory side these these people
doing lattice qcd are going to improve
those calculations the people doing
other kinds of theory calculation using
these these ratio methods they're going
to improve as well
i i'm confident that with some time a
true consensus will form in the theory
community i just don't know how long it
will take but
it seems you know like that's something
that will happen in the time ahead
and then on the experimental front um
the result that fermilab announced today
is only the very beginning that's the
data from what they call run one
they've already collected data from run
and run two and run three and those are
being processed now
in a year's time or something we'll hear
about that run four
is is ongoing so we're going to see
the the uh uncertainties associated with
this measure make it smaller and smaller
and smaller in the years ahead
um so this is this you should just think
of this as the very very beginning
of uh a fermilab's program to measure
this quantity g minus two and then there
are other kinds of experiments i
mentioned a large hadron collider that's
gonna tell us stuff that's complementary
to this
um there are a variety of other
experiments uh all of which are going to
help
flesh this out um this is not something
that we
we just fundamentally can't test this is
something that we're going to sort out
um we have the power and the technology
and knowledge to do it so another
question before we turn to
some questions from clubhouse we take
one last question
from youtube for the moment so rain lou
is asking can you elaborate a bit more
on the lands
on the implications of these results
regarding the
dark matter landscape sure rain
um thanks for the question um so
it's possible and we don't know for sure
but it's possible that these results of
fermilab have reported do have something
to do with the question of dark matter
i'll give you just a couple of examples
of ways they could be connected
but just keep in mind we don't know that
this really connected or not it's just a
possibility
but let's say that um supersymmetry is
responsible for this for this
uh discovery for this uh result we have
observed today
um that means that there are these
exotic particles and masses of a few
hundred gv
and the lightest supersymmetric particle
has long been considered one of the
most promising candidates for dark
matter it's possible that's true
and it's possible it interacts and and
uh in in
interacts uh in in ways that involve
these heavier particles that are
that are responsible for the g minus two
result so
in this sense maybe supersymmetry is
responsible both for dark matter
and for the result that fermilab
announced today similarly you could
imagine that um what we're observing at
the in
g minus two is from some sort of new
light force
and maybe that light force that that
exotic force this very feeble
but um but perceptible force might be
responsible for how the dark matter
interacts with
with itself and with other kinds of
particles so
i i will as somebody who thinks a lot
about dark matter and in a fairly large
portion of my research program is is
fixated on dark matter
i'm definitely going to be thinking more
about how dark matter might be connected
to this anomaly
and and what kind of self-consistent
pictures we could uh emerge and how we
could test them
that's excellent um so dan as i
mentioned in the beginning i feel we as
scientists have a moral obligation
to explain the work that we do in terms
lay people can understand
and also it's part of the fun of what we
do getting to talk to people that aren't
experts
as i said earlier you know there are
people i have to talk to in life
for my job shall we say and there are
people i want to talk to
and i find one of the most uh enjoyable
parts of being in the podcast world as
my
uh night job although it's not quite
night here in california
i get to bring brilliant people like
yourself
uh to the general public and i let them
ask questions
in real time either on youtube at dr
brian keating
or here on clubhouse so one of the
innovative things the few things that i
am proud of is that i get to inter i
have interact between a live audience
and clubhouse with you which is a live
audio
drop-in listening version of twitter in
a certain sense
uh although there are many people much
better equipped to explain it than me
but i thought now we take an opportunity
to talk to some people live
clubhouse and if you're on clubhouse you
can go to brian keating
dr brian keating dr brian keating on
youtube and you can see dan answer your
questions
uh but for now i'm gonna turn it over
the opportunity to ask the first
question to my good friend dr eric
weinstein
who is a proprietor of of not
insignificant
influence on me podcast as well as many
new mathematical and theoretical physics
phenomena that i find quite fascinating
and i thought eric and i could talk for
a little bit
about philosophy because you are a deep
thinker dan love
i'd love to pick your brains about kind
of the current landscape
outside of the g minus two so if you
came for g minus two like most of my
audience
you can you can turn it off now because
now we're going to go deep into
philosophy
and even touch upon things that you know
businesses should never do
like the god equation so now i want to
ask my good friend
uh dr eric weinstein to open up the
floor and perhaps provide us with some
provocative
uh uh peregrinations in the world of
theoretical particle physics that's as
many p's as i can muster eric are you
there my friend
plausibly um
uh i guess my first uh my first question
and by the way hello dan
um here nice to meet you nice to meet
you
uh it has to do with sort of the long
period between um
when we used to have this really
thriving dialogue between
new experiments and theories made back
in
adronic resonance days of the 50s and
60s
uh how does the
g minus two uh results if they hold up
or even
even at the sort of in between level um
how does that change the game when my
read over the last
40 years is that theoretical physics has
now
moved into a very abstract state where
it's not even clear
that people are really working on what i
would consider the physical world so
much as the mathematics
associated to quantum field theory and
its extensions does this
change the game and bring the people
who let's say are publishing to hep th
high energy physics
theory does this bring them back closer
towards things that actually matter
through precision experiments
or um does it continue to be two
separate worlds with people doing
mathematical investigations that don't
have a lot to do
with what seems like the physical world
that we all inhabit
well so i want to emphasize that the
theory community
is broad and certainly not monolithic
i'm part of the theory community and i
don't think i've ever
posted the hep th so uh what let me
explain for the listeners what that
means so
there's a prepin archive and there are
different categories in that archive
where you put your papers
sometimes i put my papers on something
called hep
ph which means high energy physics
phenomenology
and sometimes i put my papers on astro
ph or astrophysics phenomenology
and other physicists and i might i might
have one or two papers on hep th i'm not
sure
but some post almost entirely to hep
theory th
and in the hep th you're more likely to
encounter papers on quantum gravity
papers on string theory uh papers on
you know more more mathematically
oriented theory
but the hep ph archive is huge there are
a very very large number of papers there
it's not like we're neglecting
the kinds of you know directly
applicable to uh
experimental physics that i think you're
referring to in the the golden age
yeah i think the phenomenology community
is not having this problem condensed
matter is not having this problem
i don't even think necessarily that
astrophysics and cosmology are having
this problem it's really very peculiar
to um the ecosystem that
veered very heavily towards geometry and
to string theory
my question is does it bring them back
towards the lab
um the short answer is i doubt it but
i'm also not sure that they
need to be pulled in that direction i
think string theorists
over the last few decades have made a
lot of substantial contributions
they've changed the way i think about a
lot of things um
and you know i don't know you you can
make
nuanced arguments about resource
allocation and
you know should we be spending as much
grant money on
strings versus something else or
whatever um but
my opinion is we're kind of roughly in
the right ballpark of the different
proportions in different directions um
you might be able to convince me that
maybe we overinvested a bit in string
theory but not not dramatically
um and and i don't want to give the any
listeners the impression that the string
theorists and the phenomenologists and
the
cosmologists whatever are are living on
their own islands
in fact we interact quite a bit um i
you know at least before covid i would
regularly have conversations with the
people doing gr
and the people doing strength theory at
the university of chicago where one of
where i
impart work um we don't have string
theorists
at very to to a real extent but there
are people who definitely post a hep th
there
and i i i have regular interactions to
them and they're very fruitful and and i
think they listen to me and my work and
they're informed
by what phenomenologists are doing um i
i think
i think there's a pretty healthy balance
in exchange of ideas across these
different approaches
to the scientific method do you think
that uh kind of portfolio
balancing you know you're you're home to
many nobel laureates in economics
and modern portfolio theory uh etc
is kind of in part founded there what
about diversification so
you know i get these emails or you do as
well you know professor hooper professor
keating i have this new theory no one
will take me seriously
uh if you help me with the math because
i'm not so good at math i'll split the
nobel prize with you
at least the the money uh i'll keep most
of that but but anyway
the point being that that we kind of
have this idea that
that um you know there is almost a
gatekeeping mechanism in place and some
reason maybe that's a good thing but
but the point uh is you know how do you
how do you filter out
what could possibly be a monopolistic
overtone in physics which may or may not
be justified i mean as this paper said
today
you know there could be tensions with
the implication for super symmetry
which has you know implications for
string theory as well with super string
theory
so you know at what point uh in the
context would we be
comfortable saying that maybe the
portfolio leans too heavily
to one side or the other yeah so
i mean i i think two different
reasonable people
could come to differing conclusions
about what the right portfolio balance
is to use
your uh metaphor there um
that being said when the funding
agencies are
deciding you know where to invest
they listen to consensus
opinions of a lot of experts and they
synthesize that information they try to
make good decisions
i don't think anyone has their head in
the sand i don't think
anyone has a totally unrealistic view
of what's likely to lead to innovation
and what's not
i mean all of it's a gamble so we don't
every time we do an experiment
every time we invest in a theoretical
physics we're hoping it will pay off and
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't um that's just the
the nature of science um but i i don't
i don't see any like you know
deeply problematic aspects of the
decision making i
i view the the community and it's uh
you know the how the funding decisions
get made and how the investments get
made to be pretty healthy
in in large part so we're talking again
with dan hooper professor
university of chicago and uh located
kind of in a hybrid superposition
between fermilab
and that fine university of chicago he's
a theoretical physicist who's made
contributions to dark matter
uh dark energy and fundamental particle
physics the
area of physics that traffics in forces
fields interactions and so on
um i didn't get to talk to you after the
large hadron uh beauty
experiment there was a lot of talk in
that experiment uh
where we had james on as well on the
podcast
discussing the implications for a fifth
force
and that was kind of surprising to me
that you know we could be in an era
where there are other forces
is there any limit to the number of
forces or is it you know every particle
could in
principle interact with another uh
particle in the standard model via some
new force that has yet to be
uncovered because we lack sufficient
experimental precision
yeah it's certainly i would even say
that it's it's
would be shocking to me if the only
forces that exist in nature are the four
that we
currently know about from measurements
um and the four we're talking about here
are gravity
electromagnetism and then the weak and
strong nuclear forces
um you know two of those were only
discovered in the 20th century maybe
you'll discover two more in the 21st
century and a few more in the 22nd
century who knows
but um i suspect that what we're looking
at here is is a situation where we
observe the the
the most powerful and most readily
accessible forces
and there are probably others that in a
more complete version
of our theory maybe a grand unified
theory or a theory of everything or
whatever
that would contain many forces beyond
those that we currently recognize and
have observed
so uh reminder those of you clubhouse is
your chance to raise your hand there's a
bunch of hands
um eric do you want to talk any anything
about
this issue that i've talked about at
least in the past
that we seem to be infatuated with
theories of everything
which would unify forces together all
four forces
uh but we don't have a good grand
unified theory yet uh
and from my perspective we're kind of
you know it's like
uh my my ten-year-old talking about the
you know the the lamborghini he's gonna
get
you know when he uh makes his first
million dollars or whatever
uh in other words he's really it's
really kind of presumptuous
to me to be talking about theories of
everything what say you dan and eric i'd
love to hear
your opinion are we being like overly uh
overly
immodest by expecting that we can come
out of the theory of everything before
we have a grand unified theory
well i would argue there might be uh
some
immodesty or something if somebody were
out there claiming that they had in
their hands
either one of these things like the
right theory that unifies the
the forces of the standard model or a
theory of everything that includes
quantum gravity or something
we don't have that yet we have
candidates for it which
have we really have sketches of those
sorts of theories but we we don't know
that any of them are right
they're just candidates and i encourage
any
physicist embarking on these sorts of
questions
to be looking for ways that we can put
whatever theory you're putting forth to
the test um
in the case of grand unified theories
this might be looking for evidence of
proton decay or it might be
making predictions about different
characteristics of the standard model
particles or things like this
in the case of uh quantum gravity
including string theory people are
talking a lot about emergent gravity
these days and making predictions on
cosmological scales for what a theory
like that might look like
um i i you know i i i'm a big uh
proponent
of of uh putting the emphasis of your
research
on those theories that can readily be
tested
um not because they're the best theories
necessarily but because it's the easiest
way to make progress
eric were you going to say something
um yeah sorry about that yeah first of
all i'm worried that some people may not
understand the unification
grand unification distinction yeah i was
going to ask you to okay
so grand unification just to make life
confusing
says don't try to do all of the forces
unified only
do three of the four and leave gravity
out of it because gravity has a
different character
so um in large measure this comes out of
the 1977 rising about
the standard model which um
certain sort of disembodied ideas
uh i think took over one of which is
maybe we can wrap up the
three forces the way two forces have
been wrapped up before
electromagnetism uh was split between
something called weak isis spin and weak
hyper charge
in a previous unification so the claim
was maybe we can get the strong force
without gravity
and i think that a large portion of the
impetus towards
full unification is
that um
because string theory wanted and by the
way i
i'm happy to disagree with dan but i
couldn't just
unbalance nature of the portfolio when
string theory came in
one of the things it wanted to do was to
say that it was
the heir apparent and in order to do
that it wanted to make the claim
that its special feature
was that it could give us a remoralized
theory of gravity
and a theory that is consistent a
quantum theory
[Music]
sorry eric you're uh breaking up there
eric can you hear me consistent theory
of quantum and you're here
now i can yeah yeah okay so
the situation was very much that uh
string theory needed to change what the
role
of theoretical physics was in order to
make string theory
the theory and that had to do with
saying theory of everything because
they were they felt they were farther
along on quantizing gravity
by leaps and bounds than anything else
and it shifted
the entire focus of the field and one
thing i've done recently is to
call attention to murray gilman's 1983
address
where he said what the big problems were
and it sounds nothing like
what we say the big problems are today
so in some sense what you're doing is
you're harkening back
to an earlier time when people thought
maybe super symmetry
maybe technicolor maybe substructure
maybe grand unification
all of these things sort of got
tri-piecemeal and in a disembodied way
none of them ended up being very
compelling because we didn't see
new physics and the result of that
was that we can't we subtly shifted
from sort of more akin to einstein's
quest for unified field theory
and more close to whitten's claim that
quantizing gravity
was the problem so i i do think brian
you're correct
that in some sense um we are focusing on
full unification when maybe we shouldn't
be
but i also think that there is a claim
to be made for the string theory
perspective if not string theory in
particular which is
it may be easier to recognize the full
structure
than it is to recognize parts of the
structure by the way when you say things
like proton decay
um you have to remember that there are
grand unified theories that don't have
it like the petit salaam theory
and that in part we keep getting kind of
led down the garden path by people who
have very strong agendas
about what physics should and shouldn't
do without recognizing
that the subtle way that you couch these
things
determines what will get funded who will
get attention
and that people are constantly arguing
for their pet theory
by changing the idea of what we should
be emphasizing given that we haven't
really had a major breakthrough with
theory leads
experiment for almost 50 years in
fundamental physics
i think i've been much more focused in
trying to say why is it that we keep
allowing the same voices to frame the
problems and i think what you're trying
to do is to say
something very important maybe maybe we
shouldn't be focusing on
uh anything that grand i think we should
focus on something
um like unification but i definitely
think we should spread our attention
in ways that we haven't before thanks
thanks uh dan do you want to respond or
should we move to uh more comments
yeah i mean i'll just say like i don't
like disagree in
spirit with a lot of that um but i
i will say that like my read of the
physics community the theoretical
physics community is that most of us
are doing that um and
and sure i mean in some sense theory has
led experiment for a long time but
that only counts if you don't count
things like
neutrino mass and oscillation which was
led by experiment
um or or and you don't count things like
uh you know detailed properties the
higgs boson or the
or all this stuff going on in cosmology
which has definitely been
been led as you know brian by uh by the
observational
program um and or or dark matter like
when you know 10 years ago we thought
very different things about dark matter
than we do now and that's because of
experimental results
so it is true that if you go to the
halls of certain
you know illustrious universities you'll
find a lot of people doing string theory
and and and thinking in these ways but
that's that's not the bulk of the
theoretical physics community the the
bulk of the theoretical physics
community
i i think uh is is closer to me than
they are that i'd win
okay thank you uh we're talking again
dan hooper
uh resetting the room as i say dan
and erica i'm doing so many clubhouse
events that even
over dinner i'll reset the room with my
family at home which is quite annoying
uh it's even more annoying than those of
us who say as i talked to
you know dan hooper and eric weinstein
and my podcast like i hate
doing that and but there's no way around
it uh so we're talking with a bunch of
illustrious people today i want to bring
up people from
uh from clubhouse so d.c adams is in the
house on the stage
dc my friend can you enlighten us and
drop us some knowledge please
thank you i mean well i'm not going
gonna drop knowledge today i'm excited
i've been
um having popcorn and champagne today
because
um i i absolutely love the hype and i
just wanted your comments on that
um regarding the grammy sound reveal of
a completely blind test
to an audience of everyone and just
allowing the public to see how science
how science is done uh without prejudice
without
um with with the skeptical consensus
this is how science done no one knows
what's going to happen and we're all
just as surprised as everyone else and
and i just want your comments as to how
both of you feel about that and brian
you're doing a wonderful job
i've been looking at everything you're
doing your growth you're a wonderful guy
and um
i really appreciate everything you're
doing for the scientific community
especially broadcast
and in the education within our public
society but thank you
thank you very much yeah dan do you want
to comment again uh sorry
we we we talked on the youtube channel a
little earlier about it but maybe dan
one more time just to recapitulate for
those that missed it on clubhouse
what it was like with uh kind of build
up you on the inside at
fermilab come on you must have known you
have the why this universe
podcast featured on ferminationlab.gov
i mean something right in the pre-covet
days i would have taken those
g minus two guys to the user center and
bought him a beer and tried to get him
to
reveal something but uh but no i you
know not only did i know but
the the people i in circles with didn't
know and uh
they you know this experiment and their
their collaborators
really went to great heroic
lengths to make sure that their own
biases wouldn't come into play in the
measurement
to keep things uh you know concealed
until the last possible minute
um you know this is the way that this is
the gold standard of how science should
be done
um you know this is this what you want
to do if you want to get the right
answer
and be sure about it
not not not the way you would do it if
you want to get the answer you want
it's what you do if you want to get the
right answer right
so dan you have a little bit more time
to spend with the audience
i have a few minutes i know we went a
little bit over so uh let's see up on
stage we got josh we got
roberta why don't we deal with roberta
first and then matthew
next great thank you that's mine's
pretty
quick and simple um i just thought um
five sigma that i thought that used to
kind of just be the bedrock
through which something would have to
cross to even start
talking about it and nowadays you know
i'll read articles and something gets a
two or a three sigma and
there's articles about it and people are
talking about it so
i know this is 4.2 i think but there's
still
quite a bit of distance between 4.2 and
5. so i'm just wondering
what that how that plays out thanks
so so historically we've we've used the
word discovery
at the five sigma level but we talk
about something um
being detected or having evidence for it
at three sigma
those are the that's the nomenclature
we've adopted for these things
um and throughout my entire career and
that started i
started grad school in 1999 so 22 years
or so ago
we've been happy to discuss uh
well sub five sigma results people write
papers on it people report it people
speculate about it
that really hasn't changed but we won't
call something
a discovery and use that word very often
unless it's five sigma
and if you're not comfortable with
talking about a 4.2 sigma
thing with with some sort of confidence
give it a year i predict this will cross
that line then
really wow okay because there was a long
pause between the brookhaven results and
there are kind of precursors to this but
um but we don't have to do another
experiment in this case brian that
they've already done run two and three
that just has to be analyzed
the run four is ongoing now um
the the the projections are that the
fermilati live experiment should have
be able to shrink those error bars
considerably in the relatively near
future
okay we got another physicist josh is up
on stage josh
what say you to professor hooper
uh i guess uh my question would just
probably primarily be you know
with these experiments that we're seeing
at fermi labs and you know kind of the
questions that are being raised about
you know the standard model
do you see that the standard model has
to be update
updated in a certain sense with uh you
know like a new theory like super
symmetry or
is it is this something that we have to
kind of like throw everything out and
start all over again
yeah so we don't know um
if this result is true and it's not just
a theory calculation issue
then there's definitely physics beyond
the center model
and that might look like super symmetry
it might look like new light forces or
any number of other things
and it might be that we can supplement
the standalone model and make it hold
together pretty well
or it might be that there's some new big
overarching principle that
we're not currently thinking about and
when we're done
the standard model will be some
approximation of something very
different looking
that's a in fact that's what i would
prefer that would be a
great time to be a scientist while you
got to discover that sort of thing
it would be like when you know einstein
replaced our old way of thinking about
space and time with relativity or when
um our way of thinking about you know
particles and and in electromagnetic
fields was replaced by all the quantum
stuff in the 1920s
like that's what every physicist dreams
of being able to live through
so the more dramatic change is called
for the happier
all be that being said it's too early to
just to say whether a big dramatic
change
is is going to be needed or not i will
just say that we have lots of reasons to
think the standard model isn't going to
be the final theory
um there's no room in the standard model
for dark matter for dark energy for
inflation for an explanation for why
there's more matter than antimatter in
the universe
all of this stuff referring for neutrino
masses all of this stuff requires
physics beyond the standard model
we just don't know what that physics
looks like yet do you see that as an
evolutionary thing or requiring a
revolutionary new way in thinking about
things i know eric
you've thought a lot about this um do
you think that i mean
impressive as this is it's based upon
you know physics that
have been have been done at least in the
qcd lattice framework
for decades and that's still yielding
fruit so any new theory it would seem to
me would have to be compatible with that
but maybe the lattice qcd is kind of the
you know old way of going about it
um you know eric what do you think about
these kind of
tried and true techniques still bearing
fruit you know 40 50 years
they were invented well i think that we
learned
something incredibly important from the
period of what i would call physics
failure but the success
of geometry inside of quantum field
theory
and associated subjects what we learned
is
the quantum field theory is not really
about the physical world
it's really a branch of mathematics that
got discovered
by people who needed it who first came
from the physical world effectively
like think of it as a kind of amazing
version
of a machine like calculus that showed
up in physics departments before it was
found to be useful much more broadly
so in part um we i don't think we're
going to be invalidating something like
quantum field theory
because quantum field theory is
effectively a
naturally occurring branch of
mathematics independent of the physical
world which is kind of a shock and
perhaps one of the most amazing things
that's happened over the last 40 years
with that said
i think people are incredibly
intimidated
just as they were let's say when the
weak force
was thought to be left right symmetric
and you had the old tau theta puzzle
people didn't want to come forward and
be ridiculed by their peers and so what
i believe
is that the really interesting models
uh probably are like dead on arrival
and that's one of the reasons we're not
making progress is that the political
economy
of people who believe things that are
heretical very often things get
uh pushed forward and out into the
public
with flaws in them so einstein famously
pushed out a theory of gravity that was
not divergence free
and before that it was even vague when
he did it with grossman
is only through the process of keeping
with the idea but of iterating
on the instantiation that these things
got fixed i believe
that we should be pushing out new
frameworks my own framework
replaces space-time with two separate
spaces
one the four-dimensional continuum and
the other one the space of metrics
which i always refer to as the space of
rulers and protractors
but it's really the space of metrics and
if that's true
then it would mean that the ten
dimensions of einstein's field equations
were the same as the ten dimensions
implicit in some of the grand unified
theories
that's a kind of a bold claim and
everybody who makes these bold claims
right now is very nervous that they're
going to humiliate themselves in front
of their colleagues i believe
that these profound shifts we can either
wait for them
where the experiment becomes
overwhelming just like we did with the
tao theta puzzle
or we can change the culture of the
field and make it possible
for people who are outside of the big
programs
to put forward bold ideas and to give
them a period of time
where we don't instantly try to put them
to the sword claiming that we're
practicing the scientific method and
that we are all children of popper
so i do think room for major new ideas
but they will need to recover
the naturality that turned out to be
quantum field theory shockingly in the
80s
uh due to efforts of people like katia
whitton quillen
and graham siegel thanks great um
so we have a couple more questions
eltham uh you have your hand up i'd like
to get to you um
and then uh i have a comment on that
maybe dan when we're waiting for some
folks to
accept that quick question for eric
okay go ahead new institution is a new
institution required
to get that foot in the door or you
don't see that as a necessary
i don't even my guess is that bitcoin
could do it real
really what it requires is simply
having some of the leaders of the field
say what needs to be said again
consider that there's a respectful
disagreement with dan
i consider the field to be wildly
imbalanced
and what is expected at this point is
for somebody of the stature of a david
gross
or frank wilczyk or an ed whitton to say
we have had the ball for far too long
with far too little progress it's time
to open it up
to crazier ideas and i want to hear
ideas that are flawed i want to hear
ideas that may have caused some trip
wires to be tripped
but we cannot sit here and continue to
claim that everything is okay
given that we the theorists are supposed
to be neck and neck with the
experimentalists
what little basic progress has happened
in fundamental physics has been
essentially all due
to brian's colleagues and experiment um
well the physics
theorists have been perfecting the
mathematics of field theory so
i really believe that it's what's really
required is that some part of the
leadership
speak to the rest of the community and
say you younger kids give us your wilder
ideas and let's not put everyone to the
sword instantaneously
dan is there uh how often do you meet
with your leader
at university do you have a leader or is
it more
you know kind of this occult of
personality that maybe eric's referring
to
yeah i mean i don't think it's either of
those things i think it's a bunch of
small research groups that talk to you
know interact and talk to each other
i don't feel any pressure to do
really anything except where i think the
science is interesting
um if the leaders of the field or the
famous famous members of the field
didn't like what i'm doing i'd be fine
um and you know i don't there's plenty
of papers i don't
particularly like on the archive and i
think they're chasing down
empty rabbit holes and i uh those people
do fine um
i think uh there's a lot of room for a
lot of different kinds of approaches to
science
um yeah i don't i just don't i just
don't recognize the problem that eric's
talking about
okay wonderful to have such a clear
disagreement and uh i very much
appreciate the cordial nature of your uh
disagreeing positions yeah same here
eric same here
yeah same here says dan uh so dana
reminder is the proprietor of the why
this universe podcast
uh to the edge of time book and other
books uh and a good friend of mine in
the show and
uh really a wonderful you know uh
voice of of uh reason that bridges the
gap between
uh different communities theoretical and
experimental so i urge you all to check
them out
on itunes or wherever fresh podcasts are
served
and a reminder that says a lot when two
a podcaster comments on another podcast
because podcasting is a zero-sum game
unlike science
science is an infinite game but unless
you can listen to two podcasts or
more simultaneously uh with two
different ears it's very hard to
share a microphone eltham is in the
room and i'd like to get uh her
commentary she's a
high energy physicist
uh hi so as you know um
the united states is making huge
investments in the dune program which is
one of these
neutrino experiments and i guess my
question is
um how do you think these recent results
from lhcp
and um g minus two would
affect that program and can you tell us
more about that if you think there will
be
um huge implications for that experiment
thank you thank you well so dune is
is uh the big flagship planned
experiment
at fermilab it's a and it's among other
things it's going to study the
characteristics of neutrinos
but it's also going to test certain
classes of grand unified theories and
other sorts of ideas so it's going to do
a wide variety of
particle physics and other science um
and the connection if there is one
between the g minus two result or the b
anomalies and and and and dune will
really depend on what's responsible for
those anomalies
um and and it's too early to say but it
would not
surprise me if it turns out that there's
uh overlapping science
here to explore um we just it's this
point
we have to figure out what's going on
here before we can say what it will look
like in these other experiments but
um the more information you have from as
many different angles as possible the
more likely it is you'll be able to
assemble a pretty coherent picture
question coming in from my youtube
channel dr brian keating you should
follow me there please
as well as following eric and dan and
their various uh past the portal for
eric weinstein
dan hooper follow him at uh dan hooper
astro
question came in on the youtube channel
comment section uh
chat section was whether or not we're
trying too hard
to make uh to quantize gravity and maybe
we should make
you know quantum mechanics geometrical
or something to that effect and maybe
that could have the twin benefit
of solving dark matter dark energy and
other puzzles so dan maybe you could
address that are we going about
the approach to quantum gravity the
theory of everything
uh and all the wrong way good so uh
i'll answer this one and then i've gotta
run brian this has been fun but um
i've gotta i've got a thing in a few
minutes so uh yeah so
there are people who are thinking about
ways of of
reformulating gravity that will solve
other problems in particular dark matter
and dark energy problems
um so far these haven't really come up
with anything that um i would call a
empirical or observational success but
i'm
glad people are thinking outside of the
conventional boxes and trying new ideas
um you know i would be thrilled if uh if
one of them
uh could make predictions that we could
we can test and find out if they're true
um there's a long history of people
studying various kinds of modified
gravity including mond
modified newtonian dynamics in this
context um but yeah so far i
it hasn't been super fruitful but that's
like i said before a lot of science is
taking a gamble
trying something and seeing if you can
make it work um i think this was a
gamble worth taking
very good and the gamble is me pitching
you to come on it's been a long day for
you in the midwest
it's uh dinner time out there i want to
thank you so much for coming on the into
the impossible podcast for your second
appearance please do come back and i'll
prefer people
other appearance earlier in the year
thank you so much i'll end the stream on
youtube
everyone can move over to clubhouse if
that's possible and we'll take
questions and answers until my phone
runs out dan thank you so much
all the best to you can't wait to talk
again thanks brian talk